remaining silent outside his home this
morning prince charles's right-hand man
michael fawcett embroiled in yet another
scandal this time the allegation is hard
to deny a letter with his signature
leaked to the sunday newspapers states
in black and white that one of the
prince's charities is happy and willing
to support an application for
citizenship and that they will apply for
an honorary cbe to be made a knighthood
the recipient of this letter a saudi
billionaire who donated tens of
thousands of pounds to organizations
linked to the prince
mr fawcett has strongly denied any
wrongdoing but has temporarily stepped
down as chief executive of the prince's
foundation in a statement the foundation
said
michael fawcett offered to step down
temporarily from active duties as chief
executive of the prince's foundation
while the trustees investigation is
ongoing
the prince's foundation has accepted
this offer michael fully supports the
ongoing investigation and has confirmed
that he will assist the investigation in
every way
but some are calling for action to go
further what i'm calling for first of
all is not for the princess foundation
to investigate it because they are
compromised
that's judging during your own court the
serious allegation which is that an
honour was offered for sale needs to be
investigated by the police because it's
a criminal offence if proven under the
1925 honours act
beyond that the whole issue of how
prince charles raises money needs to be
properly investigated a palace source
has told us that clarence house will not
be commenting and rather they say this
is a matter for the prince's foundation
they have confirmed though that prince
charles has been made aware of the
allegations and while they say that the
prince and mr fawcett are not friends
there's no denying that this is a man
the prince trusted one who he worked
very closely with and a man who's been
by his side for decades
michael fawcett was just 17 when he
started his royal career as a footman to
the queen he rose the ranks quickly to
become prince charles's valet and one of
his closest advisors despite a series of
controversies including bullying
allegations in 1998 and alleged racist
comments he was repeatedly brought back
into the royal fold in 2003 he resigned
for the second time after an inquiry
into selling royal gifts but he
continued to work with prince charles
first as a freelance party planner and
then leading one of the prince's pet
projects the renovation of dumfries
house before being appointed chief
executive of the prince's foundation in
2018.
these allegations of cash for honours
are hugely embarrassing for the prince
but are ones he can't easily hide from
instead he's under pressure too there
are questions over how much he knew
about what was going on at his own
charities and of undue influence over
the honor system it could be a long wait
though for any answers charlotte lomas
sky news